Speaker 1: All right.
I'm not going to do this to you even every
week.
Never mind every day for the next two years.
But because last night failed, former President
Donald Trump announced another run for president
in 2024.
We have to look at what the polling says right
now, not only about Trump versus other Republicans,
but also general election polling.
I was telling you earlier, we have a very
different situation now for Trump's run than
we did in 2016 or 2020.
Now, Donald Trump, number one, has become
a clear loser.
2018 wasn't great for Republicans.
2020 was a disaster for Trump and Republicans,
and 2022 was the red wave that I guess could
have been but wasn't for Republicans.
And so now you have a Republican electorate
not completely sick of and tired of Trump,
but certainly much more so than in years past.
And you have a guy that is very well-liked
among Republicans, and that is Ron DeSantis,
the governor of Florida, who was just reelected
by a 19 nearly 20 point margin.
That is a blowout win for Ron DeSantis.
We don't yet know the impact of last night's
announcement that Donald Trump is running
on the polling.
But we do have a bunch of polls released after
the November 8th midterms and they're very
bad for Donald Trump.
Let's take a look at this.
You can find this on the 538 Republican primary,
2024 page.
And what we see is that there is a seven letter
insight poll released today that shows Ron
DeSantis plus eight over Donald Trump still
with a lot of undecideds.
We do have a single morning consult poll from
yesterday that still shows Trump ahead by
14 over DeSantis.
But then we have a CWC Research poll looking
at Texas, which has DeSantis plus 11 over
Donald Trump in Georgia, Florida, New Hampshire
and Iowa.
WPA intelligence polls, which are okay, they're
rated A, B, C by FiveThirtyEight.
All have Ron DeSantis ahead between plus 11
and plus 26.
We have a larger poll of the national Republican
primary which has the Santos at plus two.
And then we have a YouGov poll which is the
best ranked pollster of all of these at a
B-plus with Ron DeSantis plus seven.
Ron DeSantis plus seven.
This is a very different situation than in
years past.
We will maybe know by Monday, maybe next Tuesday
or Wednesday what the polling looks like after
Trump's announcement.
Will Trump's announcement help him in that
it will invigorate people to say, okay, DeSantis
isn't even running.
Trump's running, I'm throwing my support behind
Trump.
Or will Trump's early announcement, which
was ill advised, according to many right wing
strategists, actually hurt Trump?
That would be an interesting thing to see.
Now, also notable and again, I'm not going
to do this to you every day or even every
week for the next two years.
If we look at general election polls for 2024
and it is so early, but it is still interesting
if you look at a new poll released by Leger,
again, a, b, c pollster in a hypothetical
Biden versus Trump matchup, it is Biden plus
three.
And in a hypothetical Biden versus DeSantis
matchup, it is the Santos plus two.
In that poll, DeSantis polling way better.
And then in a bunch of different Biden polls
for 2024 from morning consult it is Biden
winning in every single one.
It's Biden defeating Christie.
Cheney.
Pompeo.
Rick Scott.
Hogan, Noam.
Tim Scott.
Tom Cotton Hawley.
Cruz.
Haley.
Romney.
Rubio.
Pence.
The best outcome is DeSantis.
DeSantis is the only one that in that poll
is even even with Joe Biden.
And then this one from right before the election,
actually, this is from New York.
New York is a very blue state, kind of meaningless.
Okay.
So the other point here is.
Trump and other Republicans, short of Ron
DeSantis, aren't even polling well in hypothetical
matchups against Joe Biden.
Joe Biden also hasn't announced that he's
running in 2024.
So a very different situation here.
We are taking a picture right now and then
we're going to give it six or so months and
see how things are looking in the spring.
But it is not at all clear.
Even though many Republicans insist this nomination
is Trump's for the taking, it is not clear
that it is really Trump's for the taking.
And it is not at all clear that if Trump wins
that nomination that he is in a strong position
to actually win in 2024.
At which point, by the way, he will be, you
know, nearly 80 years old.
And that's a whole other story which we will
get to.
The point is this could all end in genuine
historic humiliation for Donald Trump